اكثر من 40 مليون مشاهده على يوتيوب
حققتها الاغنيه الاخيره الفنان الكويتي
الشاب حمود الخضر مشتركه مع الفنان ماهر
زين الاغنيه التي حملت اسم تهيا جاءت
بمناسبه كاس العالم في قطر 2022 والمنتهي
قبل ايام ولاقت اشاده كبيره حمود الخضر
فنان كويتي شاب موسيقي عرف باغانيه
المفعمه بالايجابيه والداعيه للافضل دوما
الامر الذي يدعو اليه الخضر في الكثير من
اغانيه حمود الذي بدا مشواره هو طالب نال
شهره واسعه على مستوى الوطن العربي باغنيه
فكره
اعلان التلفزيون واداء شاره البرنامج
التلفزيونيه رمضانيه الاشهر خواطر لاحمد
الشقيري
منذ سنوات وتحديدا في عام 2015
حين اطلق البومه وهو الشهير اصير احسن
الذي نال الكثير من الاعجاب والاقبال بس
هي ما من الشباب واغنيه كن انت كان ثالث
اكثر الاغاني العربيه مشاهده في عام 2015
[موسيقى]
اعتقد يبحث عن نقطه تتميزه عن همم عن
زملاء الفلاح انا من البدايه يمكن همم كان
عندي اهتمام بطرح مواضيع مختلفه عن
الموجوده في السوق همم السوق عندنا الفني
في الوطن العربي وعظماء العاطفيه اعتقد هي
يعني
مهمه تكون موجوده لانها اقوى المشاعر هي
مشاعر العاطفه والهدف من الاغنيه
والموسيقى انها توصل مشاعر لكن ايضا لقيت
ان في مساحه كثيره من المواضيع همم نادرا
ما يطرق لها الفن العربي
مواضيع حياتي اجتماعيه
فقلت اجربها والحمد لله لقينا فيه يعني
اقبال كبير من الجمهور عليها محمود سمعنا
انه انت من اصعب الطلبات اللي بتنطلب في
حياتك انك تفيق بكير فيحنا يعني احنا بنقد
كثير وجودك معنا هون في الاستديو بهذا
الساعه المبكره من الصبح
بس انا عندي كمان سؤال اذا حمود هل حمود
يؤمن بالحب يؤمن بالرومانسيه هل سنرى حمود
الخضر في اغنيه رومانسيه في المستقبل لا
الاغاني الاجتماعيه ذات الرسائل
بالرومانسيه همم وعلى صعيد الاغاني ممكن
تشوف لي نشوف لي يعني او اغني اغنيه
عاطفيه اذا قدرت اترحب بزاويه مختلفه وغير
مكرره اطرحها من زاويتي يكون فيها يعني
همم قيمه يعني قيمه معينه حمود
شو السر اغنيه سينجل عندك خصوصا انه ساهمت
في زياده شعبيتك وكان لها ملايين
المشاهدين يعني انا اعتقد الان نمط
الاستماع الجمهور للموسيقى
كامل الان استماع صار من خلال الانترنت في
اليوتيوب ولا في تطبيقات فالواحد صار يسمع
بس الاغنيه المفضله بالنسبه له
فاعتقد نمط السنجل مع نمط استخدام استماع
الجمهور صار افضل من من فكره طرح البوم مع
ذلك كان عندي البومين يعني اصير احسن لكن
اعتقد الجاي معظم راح يكون السنجلز
الجمهور كله
طبعا انا قلت لكم قبل الهواء يعني الصوت
اليوم
مرحبا وسهلا كل من محله هذا العالم وسعبت
انا واحلى زينا المباني حققنا الاماني عيش
اللحظه معنا ودندن ودان داني الملعب جمعنا
يلا غنوا معنا نغمه عربيه
[موسيقى]
ويلا تهيا بسم الله ابتدينا يا مرحبا حيه
هيا هيا هيا الحلم بسمانا وعلى الوعد جانا
يلا نلعب
سويها
هيا هيا هيا
[موسيقى]
بسم الله
يا مرحب